[Music]
do you like me yet
figure it out okay here I go here I go
here I go again ladies what's my
weakness okay when I was growing up I
had a dog and he actually inspired me to
get a job working with animals I got one
I was the dog killer at the Humane
Society no I felt guilty about it I was
getting paid to do something I'd
probably be doing anyways I did have a
dog it's actually a sad story he bit a
little boy in the face we had to have
him killed parents you're more okay with
me killing a kid I I realized I'm a
comedian I want to tell you a quick
story about my grandmother who passed
away recently which is sad you know it's
a bummer but she was in her late 90s as
part of life you got to deal with I'm
sure some people here have a dead old
grandma or whatever by random applause
how many people have a debt now again
it's sad part of life could I deal with
it one of the last few days of my
grandma's life was spent in a hospice
home surrounded by her family and it was
getting late one night we're getting
hungry we decided to order a pizza pizza
delivery guy shows up to the hospice
home and they direct him back to the
room that we're all on it when he shows
up we're like pizza's here right grandma
that's exactly the moment my grandma
died
all right thanks a lot that's it for me
thank you
I'll keep going that's a true story that
really happened like what do you do and
that you pay the pizza guy right first
things first you tip him he watched a
person died I thought about he should
have been like free pizza sorry for your
loss he didn't we paid full price for
the pizza
mostly I'm still curious how long do you
have to wait till you eat a slice of
pizza in that situation all right we all
agreed we were hungry 20 minutes ago my
guy was actually here tonight
she's got free pizza for everybody
coming out grandma she passed away well
before I got here I want to tell you
about my book I wrote a book I'd
appreciate it if you go buy it it would
help me financially it's not really a
funny funny but it's not a comedy book
it does have some funny parts but today
I'm excited to share with you as we just
did the audio book so I get to I'm gonna
play a just a quick clip of my audio
book for you and just you know consider
it as a book that you would buy or
whatever but here we go just a quick
clip of my audiobook enjoy growing up I
was a fairly normal child nothing too
out of the ordinary really just a kid I
never really got into too much trouble
I did what I was told for the most part
and kept a low profile I went to school
just like everybody else and paid
attention but when I got home from
school is what I did most of my real
learning
I was very alright you don't like it
it's just a book well you know something
else kind of interesting about it you
know like on a DVD they would do a
director's commentary we tried that out
with my book actually haven't had a
chance to hear it yet growing up I never
really got it was a real fun
opportunities for me to actually get it
to write to school
thank you I don't know why you're
clapping that's very nice though that's
it for me thanks a lot everybody
[Applause]